Muslim. Here
[Silence]
we have a narration on the authority of
Abi
Abu Bakari.
This companion
is from
and
is a people that went to war against the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
and his companions
in a well-known battle referred to as
is an area
in which the prophet sallallah.aii
alaihi wasallam and his companions
had
laid under siege
the
fortress if you will for lack of a
better term of
he got his nickname Abu Bakr Abu Bakr.
You know we said before that abu or
in the Arabic language this is referred
to as a ka abua
right and that most usually the
tradition of the Arabs is that they
would give the kuna to an adult and it
would be their eldest boy that the kuna
would be named after. So a person has
number of sons. the oldest son is
named Ahmed, he would be Abu Ahmed and
the mother would be Omu Ahmed, right?
And so forth. However, this isn't always
the case. Often times they would give a
kuna even if a person has
children they would name the kuna
after a younger son or even a daughter
which is much more rare but occurs. Why?
Because perhaps they have a number of
sons, but the middle or youngest son
happens to be a tribesman or happens to
be u a great warrior who becomes very
famous or very popular, well-known or
perhaps becomes a great scholar. And so
now out of honor they would name the
father the after this younger
or also because of an incident that
occurs. So for instance
his abass
hass his oldest son is al hass
however he has another ka that the
prophet sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam
gave him which is Abu Tab Abu. Why Abu
Tab? Because
got into a spat with Fatima
and you know he he went to cool off and
he went to the masid
to you know he was laying down in the
masid. He he left his home and he went
to the masid. The prophet sallallah.aii
alaihi wasallam saw him there sleeping
in the masid on the ground on the dirt
and he said
right so he called him Abu Turab after
this incident where he was sleeping on
the ground on the dirt bik
in the Arabic language is a pulley a
pulley right we know the the the
pulley it's a pulley it's a
what is water. It's water, right? a
pulley is a wheel that is usually
hung up. It's got a hook over it, right?
And the way that they would bring heavy
objects up onto the fortress walls or
over the fortress walls, right, is that
they would have these pulleys on a boom
hanging out over the fortress wall and
they would have a rope on it and they
detach something. And we've all seen
this in a well or well this
fortress on its walls it had these
bakarat or these pulleys.
And when the prophet sallallah.aii
alaihi wasallam and his companions laid
siege on Ben and in
what happened was there were a number
roughly about 23
slaves that
became Muslim. And during this siege
when they saw the prophet sallallah.aii
alaihi wasallam came. They came down off
of this wall. They accepted Islam and
they became part of the Muslim. Abu Bakr
was the third one to come down on that
pulley.
He was a he was a slave in and he was
the third one to grab onto that rope and
come down off of that bakra off of that
pulley to join the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam's ranks. And so he was
later known as Abu Bakr, Abu Bakr
because of this incident when he
accepted Islam and came down off of this
pulley.
And so his name is Nu Nu. And it's said
that his name is Mas. He's Arab. He's
Arab. Often times when we say slave
because of the
west and we live here in the west
what's in our mind is slavery of the
western type right which is only only
black only African and this terrible
nightmarish kind of scenario but that's
not how slavery was in a lot of the
world and it's certainly not how slavery
was in the time of Jahia an Arab could
become a slave as a matter Matter of
fact, a nobleman could become a slave
depending on the situation, right?
People became slaves for seemingly petty
issues. They could become a slave
because their family didn't have enough
money to
get buy something. Could be food for the
year or could be weapons for a war or
a battle. And so they put their son or
sons as collateral and they never are
able to pay it back. And so this son now
is a slave to the owner. Or it could be
because they are kidnapped. Or it could
be because they are taken as a prisoner
of war. Or it could be for a multitude
of reasons. Could be a gambling debt,
right? Could be that they're very poor.
They're dirt poor. or they're found out
in the desert somewhere what
happened with Ysef Alisam. These are all
ways that a person could become a slave.
Abu Bakr was a slave and he when he
switched sides and he became Muslim in
the battle of
his name is Nuf and it said that his
name is Masur but the majority of the
scholars view that Masur is actually the
name of his father. His father's name is
Masur.
Abu Baka became
later on moved on to become a more major
companion and there's a reason that he
said this narration specifically.
Now Abu Bakr
later moved to Albas after the prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam's death
and after the moving of
the and the capital of the Muslim empire
from Medina to Iraq he moved to
Iraq
and
during these days here in the year 36
After Hijra, there was an incident that
took place, a misunderstanding
that sparked a skirmish between
some of the companions
and their armies
which is known as
is referred to because of the camel the
camel of
that she was on. She had her held on,
which is a little kind of tent or
room that would be on top of for for
women. And the battle was ended or
the skirmish was ended. It was more of a
skirmish than it was a battle. But it
was ended when Ali
commanded that her camel be
an
is striking the the leg of the camel for
it to to fall over and this kind of
ended the skirmish. Now this was a
misunderstanding and it was inflamed by
the at the time. This is a long story
but you know why I bring it up. One of
the huge misunderstandings that the
Muslims have or a lot of Muslims have is
with regards to some of the incidents
that occurred in the time of the
companions
especially after the murder of the
greatifman
were there
a couple of battles that took place
amongst the Muslim armies of Ashe and
Iraq at the time. Yes. Were companions
involved? Yes. But usually when people
think about the battle or the incidents
that occurred
around this time between the companions
they imagine that all of the prophet's
companions all the home split into two
factions into two halves and all of them
started fighting with each other and
this is very
this is a very misunderstood thing
and that is that Islam
mentions that when we gather all of the
names of every companion that had
anything to do with the
misunderstandings that took place
during these times whether it is in
Safian or whether it is in J or what
have you it was only about 30 companions
that were involved only 30. We say only
30. the ratio of those who were
involved compared to those who were not
involved is extremely lopsided because
mentions that
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam had
more than 100,000 companions with him.
100,000
companions with him in
in the ninth year after Hijra.
Out of those 100,000 that were still
alive 30 years later, only about 30 of
them had any involvement in Saf and Al
collectively combined, right?
And not only that, but the the
skirmish of Al was not supposed to be a
battle. It was just a meeting. and
was there because she had gone to try to
bring peace between the two factions
that had disagreed with one another.
Because when
was murdered,
some of the companions viewed that
the most important thing right now is
for us to stabilize the country,
stabilize the empire, stabilize the
right, which is the correct opinion. We
need to stabilize the the
after that we will bring the
murderers of man to justice.
the other side was no we will not
pledge allegiance to the new Khalifa
until
men's killers are brought to justice.
Right? Both of them desired what they
knew and understood to be correct. And
it's not our position to judge any of
the companions.
But the point is is that from this
misunderstanding which is
both of them view
look at this both sides but all the
companions agree the kilafa needs to be
stabilized.
All the companions agree that the
killers of the killers of man need to be
brought to justice.
However, what did they disagree on?
Which one takes precedent over the the
other? Which one comes first over the
other? So, it's just two different ways
of looking at the same thing.
Which is why they never took war booty
from each other. They never took spoils
of war. They never took prisoners of
war. They continued to marry to one
another and deal with one another off of
the battlefield. This was
as professional as it can get, right?
You know when they say it's not
personal, it's just a professional. This
is as professional as it could get, if
you will. And so Abu Bakr was in al-Bas
and he saw a very well-known
famous
and scholar known as Alb
his u his nickname was al because his
feet were were pigeon toaded. So he
called him
and he had his sword and he was headed
somewhere and Abu Bakr saw him and he
said to where are you going with that?
He said,
he said, I'm going to give victory to
the messengergers's cousin,
meaning Ali.
And so Abu Bakr said to him,
[Silence]
And so he narrated to him this narration
and this is how this narration reached
us today in
Muslim
and
subhanahu
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
What?